l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 618 d'Eric Doliger un
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur la
parole est à Éric Doliger auteur de la
question merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
vous savez monsieur le ministre que la
situation économique sociale et
financière de notre pays n'est pas
facile en ce moment et on a rien trouvé
de mieux que de revoir complètement les
conditions électorales dans un certain
nombre de collectivités dont les
conseils généraux et je vais me
permettre de vous questionner à ce sujet
vous savez que l'article nouveau 31-13
du Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales indique que le Conseil
général doit se prononcer dans un délai
de six semaines à compter de sa saisine
par le gouvernement au sujet de sa
nouvelle carte électorale des cantons
le saisine d'autant plus importante
qu'une telle refondation de la totalité
des cantons n'a pas de précédent dans
l'histoire de notre pays depuis plus de
deux siècles à l'expiration de ces 6
semaines la vie est réputée rendue pour
un sujet aussi fondamental pour la vie
démocratique de la nation et de ses
territoires aucune disposition de
prévoit le caractère public de la
saisine du Conseil général il en résulte
une très grande incertitude quand elle
efficacité de cette saisine dans un
certain nombre de départements dans ces
conditions il est indispensable que vous
garantissiez le caractère public de la
saisine des conseils généraux afin que
ceux-ci puisse réellement exercer leur
compétences dans le cas contraire
certains conseils généraux pourraient
être réputés avoir rendu un avis sur une
question dont il n'aurait pas connu
l'existence
il conviendrait également que la LED de
transmission des projets de cartes
cantonale adressées au préfet comporte
les instructions pour que le débat sur
ce sujet est lieu obligatoirement en
assemblée plénière publique enfin je
vous demande et vous remercie de nous
faire le point à ce jour du nombre
décisions déjà effectuées des conseils
généraux des avis qui ont été rendus par
les assemblées départementales du sens
de ces avis démocratiques et du nombre
de décrets de redécoupage transmis à
cette date au Conseil d'État vous
comprendrez monsieur le ministre que
pour un sujet aussi essentiel pour la
vie démocratique de nos territoires la
précipitation et le calcul politicien
doivent céder devant la réflexion
sereine et la clarté publique merci
merci Monsieur d'Olivier la parole est à
Monsieur kaderharif ministre chargé des
anciens combattants madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs le sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'olivier
le mistral intérieur regrette de ne
pouvoir être présent parmi nous ce matin
il m'a chargé donc de vous transmettre
les éléments suivants comme vous le
rappelez dans votre question monsieur
sénateur l'opération de remodelage de la
carte électorale menée actuellement est
inédite mais elle était nécessaire
d'abord parce que vous le savez bien nos
départements ne comptent que 13,5% de
femmes élues cette situation n'était
plus tenable et la loi du 7 mai 2013 est
venue apporter des réponses concrètes
avec le scrutin binominal paritaire
cette loi instaure enfin la parité aux
élections départementales ensuite parce
que l'écart de population entre le
canton le plus peuplé le moins peuplé
pouvait aller jusqu'à 1 pour 47 et cela
dans un même département dans votre
département du Loiret monsieur sénateur
s'est écart est aujourd'hui de 1 à 5
cela signifie-t-il que suivant le canton
où l'on réside la voix de l'homme vaut 5
fois moins ce que celle de l'autre
question qui est posée le rhumodelage
des cantons il a encore une cité
démocratique et l'application de la loi
du 17 mai que la voix de chacun nos
concitoyens et partout la même valeur
des critères de se redécoupage sont
connus ce sont ceux qui a défini le
Conseil constitutionnel dans sa
juryprine jurisprudence le premier
principe est celui de l'égalité du
suffrage et donc du respect du critère
démographique la nouvelle carte ne
pourra scanner que de manière restreinte
voire pour tenir compte des spécificités
géographiques impératives les principes
sont donc transparents quant à la
procédure sur laquelle vous interrogez
est également connu de tous dans chaque
département les préfets à la demande du
ministres intérieure ont consulté des
principaux élus et notamment les
Présidents de Conseils Généraux toutes
les propositions précises ont été
transmises au ministère de l'intérieur
c'est sur ces bases que les projets de
décret de découpage sont élaborés avant
d'être transmis au Conseil généraux pour
recueillir la vie de l'assemblée
départementale à ce jour 46 projets ont
été transmis au Conseil Général et 30
votes ont déjà eu lieu dont 19 positifs
cette consultation est prévue par
l'article 46 de la loi mai 2013
concernant les modalités de cette
consultation il semble utile de préciser
le sens de l'article
l313-2 nouveau du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales cet article
impose une séance plénière du conseil
général et non une simple réunion de la
commission permanente les documents sont
donc transmis par le conseil général aux
membres de l'Assemblée comme tout
document de cession le délai d'envoi
peut varier selon le réglement intérieur
de l'Assemblée départementale mais le
plus souvent cette transmission de voir
doit avoir lieu au moins 12 jours ouvrés
à ma naissance vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur il s'agit d'une délibération
publique et l'assemblée départementale
en est pleinement informé enfin après
cet avis le Conseil d'État examine
chacun des projets de décret au regard
des principes qui figurent dans la loi
et dans la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel à cette date 24 projets
ont été transmis au Conseil d'État les
15 dossiers déjà examinés par la section
de l'Intérieur ont tous reçu un avis
favorable avec parfois quelques
modifications le rôle de l'âge de la
carte cantonale vous le voyez se fait
dans le strict respect du droit et en
toute transparence avec les conseils
généraux merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur d'Olivier souhaitez-vous
répondre à Monsieur ministre
monsieur le ministre de votre réponse et
des éléments précis qu'il contiennent au
niveau quantitatif bon je vous remercie
de m'avoir rappelé les éléments
principaux du débat qui ont lieu mais
qu'on connaît par cœur bien sûr sur la
féminisation les écarts les critères etc
l'important c'est de savoir
effectivement comment est consulté
l'assemblée qu'il y est un débat public
et comment où on en est aujourd'hui des
décisions qui ont été prises et des
cartes qui ont été transmises j'ai bien
noté qu'à peu près 50% des départements
si j'ai bien compris puisqu'il y en a 48
ont reçu leur carte qu'un tiers à peu
près en voté et que sur ce tiers 19 ont
été positifs donc on voit qu'il y a
quand même un certain nombre d'avis
d'avis négatif si j'ai bien compris les
examens qui ont été faits au Conseil
d'État sur ceux qui ont été transmis et
les examens qui ont été donnés
ils sont tous favorables avec quelques
modifications donc ce qui sera
intéressant de connaître quel est le
sens des modifications et qu'elles ont
été les différentes réponses aux
observations qui ont été faites par les
différents
départements il sera intéressant
peut-être de publier régulièrement les
résultats des consultations qui ont été
faites de manière à ce que nous
puissions avoir une transparence totale
dans ce domaine je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre merci chers
collègues